[Music]
hello and welcome to lesson two
on scatter plots where we will be going
over the basics of plotting and
customizing scatter plots
using the built-in plotting functions so
scatter plots are probably the most
common type of plot in ecology
because it shows the relationship or
lack thereof
between two continuous variables so
first we're going to load our data and
we're just going to load the same plant
growth data as from the previous lesson
by running this line with data plant
growth it loads the built-in data
and we can see that it has two columns
which represents
plant dry weight the plants were grown
using three different treatments which
are represented by group
control treatment one and treatment two
and then they were collected and dried
and waited wait waited excuse me
i don't even know how to say that waited
and
this is in grams all right so then we're
also going to append this
extra water data that we have for the
data set which represents how much
water in liters was added to each plant
throughout its lifespan
so we're going to just run this line all
the numbers should already be in here
and then we'll add that to the plant
growth data using this dollar sign water
to create a new column
called water with these water data so as
we learned in the previous lesson
we can just simply create a plot using
the plot function
and then say weight
is a function of water and then define
the data set
data equals plant growth
and when we run that we get this very
simple
scatter plot of weight as a function of
water
now let's go over all the most common
basic customizations you will need to
know when creating figures this way
so first let's talk about the axes let's
make sure that the axis labels are more
informative
so we can do that by modifying the xlab
and y
lab arguments in the plot function so
let's just copy and paste this
so we don't have to keep rewriting it
and then
we'll hit a comma to add a new argument
and keeping in mind that r is not really
space sensitive
and so we can actually for keeping to
keep this a little bit neat instead of
having it be one long line that keeps
going out now
we can just hit return after that comma
and just add the new arguments here
just to keep it a little more organized
that's totally up to you however you
prefer to do it
all right so we'll add in the xlab
argument
and so for the x label we'll call it the
x label
is water we'll call it total water
in liters like that and another comma
there then we'll do the
y lab argument equals dried
biomass weight
in grams all right so now when we run
this
the x and the y labels have been
rewritten based on this x-lab and y-lab
argument
then let's add a little bit more space
around the points
by making the axis ranges a bit larger
using the
x-limb and the y-limb arguments so what
i mean is for example these points are
very
close to the edge and maybe just for
visual say for
composition's sake you want to add a
little more space around these points
just to keep it a little
i don't know maybe you think it'll look
better this way so
we'll do exlim equals and then you add a
little vector using the concatenate
function or the c
that ranges from the minimum x value to
the maximum x value that we want
so let's go from a little bit
more let's add a little space here by
starting at 1.25
and then go all the way to 3.75
okay and then y
limb do the same thing we'll start at
3.25 and go to
6.75 and now let's run that
and there you go added quite a bit of
space this might be too much space but
it's i'm just kind of doing this to show
to
show you how it works okay so now let's
move on to the points themselves
let's change the shape of the points to
circles that are filled in
by changing the pch parameter sometimes
open circles like this are useful
especially when you have a lot of
overlapping points because then you can
see them
but other times i think in most cases
it's nice to just have filled in circles
so we'll do that and again we'll just
copy and paste this down here
so we don't have to rewrite the whole
thing and we'll add in the arguments
or the argument pch equals
16. and if we run that you'll see that
the points are all now filled in
now you can play around there's a lot of
different pch values you know if we did
10 for example we get these circles with
crosses inside
if we did nine we get these squ
diamonds with crosses there's all sorts
of different symbols
with using pch but 16 is the most common
and the the simplest and and best to use
in most cases
so we can also change the color of the
points using the col function
and then we can even we can just use
quotes and write out
red for example and run that and now all
the points
are red it's important to keep in mind
that a good best practice
to remember is that plots are generally
much better to keep in grayscale
or black and white unless it's
absolutely necessary to include color
and in the case of this figure there
really isn't a reason to
there isn't a reason not to keep the
points black because there aren't
different categories or anything else we
want to
show it's just simply the biomass and
how it
changes with how much plants were
watered so there's really no
nothing helpful about making those
points red so
just keep it to black or we can erase
that all together since the default is
always going to be black
finally we can change the size of the
points using the cex
argument and the default is one which
represents
100 percent so the points right now are
displayed at 100 percent
of their size so if we add in cex
equals 1.5 now they will be
150 percent larger
want to make them really big we can
double their size by making cex equals
two
great so that's it for this lesson as a
quick review
we went over a review of using the plot
function
then we went over modifying the axis
labels modifying the axis ranges
modifying the shape color and size of
points
and that's it so next we're going to go
over the basics of plotting
and customizing box plots so thanks for
watching hope you enjoyed
and see you in the next lesson
[Music]